speaking of wearing out over time
i don't know you know my transitions
here um what what do you think about
what's your opinion on these protests in
front of these justices houses
apparently
uh i
this is what i think i think
that people complaining about people
showing up to kavanaugh sauce a house i
i i
i think it's totally fine i think it's
totally fine they're just getting into a
little good trouble they're not causing
any harm right obviously that's that's a
problem right there but if you look at
if you look at brett kavanaugh and every
one of these other supreme court
justices that are trying to or or
republicans the gop they are violating
other people's rights right and only it
starts here and it's going to continue
on to where it's like oh i'm gonna go
into your house because
uh
we you know we believe we heard
that uh you are pregnant and we don't
want you get up you know an abortion i'm
not saying it'll go that far but i am
saying like the extreme of feeling
violated in your own home imagine how a
woman feels their own body feels
violated because they through whatever
means now have to have a child that they
don't want they don't don't feel like
they have the resources or they don't
have the the proper support to help
raise so they say i want an abortion
there's nothing wrong with that but
according to the gop in the supreme
court
yeah they're just uh
they have to have the kid right what
what did what did lido say he said
domestic uh
domestic supply of infants well i mean
you know you gotta have inventory gabe
you gotta have inventory
and we can't we can't we can't we can't
have people being loud
on public sidewalks in front of
justice's houses that is just
intolerable in this country we cannot
have people holding megaphones and
saying things that make these fascists
uncomfortable get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] look and frankly frankly
they're trying to equate people being
loud on a street in front of a justice's
house because they're trying to strip
away people's rights away from them
right
equating it to an insurrection look if
it were the insurrection people would be
going to the supreme court they would be
breaking down the doors breaking windows
uh erecting a gallows in front of the
supreme court and threatening to hang
the justices they are not doing that
that is not a thing they're doing
they're not going in the supreme court
they're not what are you are you saying
that these people are actually
protesting yes i am violent
safe you know do you know what scares do
you know what terrifies fascists do you
know what terrifies them absolutely free
speech terror yet yeah and protest
i mean it is it is a thing that
absolutely terrifies him and has for
years and someone sent me uh anonymous
has this uh i want to play this
anonymous uh posted this video from
telecomics canada um
i'm not sure it is a rendition of woody
guthrie do you know woody guthrie is you
know what he got three is
the name sounds familiar so woody
guthrie is a folk music
um he wrote folk music and he had a
guitar and the guitar on the guitar it
says
this machine kills fascists he wrote do
you know the song this land is your land
oh yes this land is my land
from the new york islands i i'm from
beginning it wrong
right so that that is that that woody
guthrie song
is a response to
um
god bless america right so uh woody
guthrie wrote that song in response to
um
god bless america but here's the thing
here's the thing is he also wrote a song
said um all you fascists are bound to
lose
all you fascists are bound to lose and
here is a great rendition that anonymous
had posted of all you fascists are bound
to lose let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
there's kids
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]